Anklage Nummer 4 gegen Donald Trump
kommt aus dem Bundesstaat Georgia und
hat es in sich eine Anklageschrift mit
fast 100 Seiten der frühere US-Präsident
wird in 13 Punkten wegen versuchen
angeklagt den Ausgang der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 zu kippen und
weitere 18 Personen sind neben Trump
aufgeführt unter ihnen sein früherer
Stabschef im Weißen Haus Mark medus und
sein früherer Anwalt Rudi Giuliani einst
Bürgermeister von New York die Anklage
fußt unter anderem auf einem Gesetz zum
Kampf gegen die organisierte
Kriminalität Verschwörung zur Fälschung
Anstiftung zum Verstoß gegen ein
Amtszeit wuchtige Vorwürfe Donald Trump
schrieb zu der Anklage heute früh auf
dem von ihm selbst gegründeten
Online-Netzwerk truse social klingt für
mich manipuliert warum haben Sie nicht
schon vor zweieinhalb Jahren Anklage
erhoben weil sie es mitten in meiner
Wahlkampagne tun wollten behauptet er
weiter Hexenjagd tatsächlich ermittelte
die leitende Oberstaatsanwältin mehr als
zwei Jahre lang gegen Trump und seine
Verbündeten denn Georgia hatte bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 als
sogenannter Swing state eine wichtige
Rolle gespielt der abgewählte Trump
hatte Anfang 2021 Georgia's Wahl Leiter
bradsons Burger in einem berüchtigten
Telefonat dazu aufgefordert doch genug
Stimmen zu finden um Trumps Niederlage
in dem Südstadt zu
Drehens Burger lehnte ab von dem Anruf
gibt es eine Tonaufzeichnung
ich treffe in diesem Amt Entscheidungen
auf Basis der Fakten und des Gesetzes
das Gesetz ist vollkommen unparteiisch
weist Oberstaatsanwältin Willis Vorwürfe
politisch motivierter Ermittlung zurück
die Angeklagten könnten sich bis zum 25
August freiwillig stellen sie Streber
ein Prozess bin sechs Monaten an
mitten im Wahlkampf dürfte es Trump mehr
als ungelegen kommen dass es in Georgia
durchaus üblich ist anklageverlesungen
live im Fernsehen zu übertragen ein
großes Spektakel
und unser USA
verfolgt die Prozesse rund um Trump
guten Tag nach Washington ja das
Verfahren das könnte im Fernsehen
übertragen werden anders als bei den
vorherigen Verfahren was macht denn
diese Anklage jetzt so besonders
ja ich glaube das Entscheidende ist dass
sie eben nach dem sogenannten ricoact
erfolgt also das ist dieses Gesetz zur
Bekämpfung des organisierten Verbrechens
und dazu kommt das eben Kameras im
Gerichtsraum erlaubt sein werden und da
muss man sich das so vorstellen dass da
am Ende 19 Angeklagte sitzen der
Anführer Donald Trump angeblich
gewissermaßen der syndikatsboss und ein
ganzes Syndikat das da angeklagt ist
dass so steht es in der Anklageschrift
organisierte und koordinierte Straftaten
begangen haben soll und das wird eben im
Fernsehen übertragen das heißt die
Menschen können die Beweisführung dann
wohl genau verfolgen und könnten sehen
anhand von Audio Mitschnitten anhand von
Bildern die es gibt aber eben auch
anhand von Zeugenaussagen und die
meisten Zeugen werden Republikaner sein
können die Zuschauer dann sehen dass es
sich hier nicht um freie
Meinungsäußerung des Präsidenten handelt
sondern eben um richtige Straftaten und
das unterscheidet dieses Verfahren eben
von den anderen was bedeutet das alles
jetzt für Trumps Chancen wieder
US-Präsident zu werden
ja nun hat er ja in den letzten Wochen
zugelegt in den Umfragen man hat also
den Eindruck mit jeder Anklage wächst
die Zustimmung aber ich glaube am Ende
schadet ihm das gewaltig er muss in
seinem Wahlkampf gewissermaßen zwischen
4 Prozessen dann wahrscheinlich hin und
her pendeln wir werden sehen was an
Beweismaterial vorgelegt wird und das
werden seine innerparteilichen
Widersacher auch als Munition gegen ihn
verwenden und am Ende werden sich
wahrscheinlich auch viele Wähler Fragen
will man jemanden der zum Beispiel in
Georgia verurteilt wurde wegen dieser
Straftaten organisiertes Verbrechen
gewissermaßen will man den zum
Präsidenten haben denn selbst wenn der
Präsident würde kann er eine
Verurteilung in Georgia nicht
zurückdrehen weil es eben ein
bundesstaatsverfahren ist während er
sich bei bundesverfahren vielleicht am
Ende als Präsident selbst begnadigen
könnte also ich glaube das wird beim
Wähler eine Rolle spielen Einschätzung
aus Verschenken von Elma Tee Wissen
vielen Dank